-We do not always
have enough time
to cover everything going on
with recent news.
So here with a recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys!
Things have been crazy!
Okay, first of all,
the U.S. Open began last week,
and I was like, "What?"
Then I saw Serena's outfit,
Then Serena hurt her ankle,
and I was like, "Oh, no.
Is the outfit okay?"
And it was.
Serena was amazing.
She beat Karolina.
She beat Petra.
And she beat Qiang so fast
that I was like, "Wha--"
'cause I didn't get time
to get out a whole "what."
Then Naomi Osaka
played Coco Gauff,
and after Naomi beat Coco,
she comforted her.
And I was like, "What?"
Then I was like,
"It's okay, Coco.
You have plenty of time
to win stuff.
You're probably
only 20 years old."
And then someone was like,
"She's 15 years old."
And I was like, "What?"
Because when people that age
accomplish big things,
it makes people my age
feel bad about themselves.
And if you ask me what my age
is, I would say, "What?"
Because my hearing is also bad.
Because I am very old.
I'm 22.
Then I found out men also play
at the U.S. Open,
and I was like, "What?"
No shade. It had honestly never
occurred to me that they might.
Then I heard everyone was
talking about the salmon cannon.
And I was like, "What?"
Salmon cannon?
You guys don't have to
make weapons
just because Trump
thinks them up.
Then people were like,
"That's not what this is.
This is a tube
that shoots salmon
so their lazy behinds
don't have to swim upstream."
And I was like, "What?"
I liked it better as a weapon.
Now, hear me out.
You shoot a salmon at
your enemy, and he'd be like,
"You hit me with a yummy fish
that's high in omega-3.
You are no longer my enemy.
You're my friend."
Everyone wins.
Then I heard that rap label
Death Row Records
was bought by a company,
and I was like,
"What's my mother[bleep] name?"
Then I was like,
"What company is tough enough
to buy Death Row?
Is it Interscope Records?
Is it Jay-Z's streaming service,
Tidal?"
Then I found out it was Hasbro.
This is real.
The toy company Hasbro
bought Death Row Records.
I was like, "What?"
My two favorite things
together at last.
My Little Ponies and Tupac.
They'll finally be able
to make my dream pony,
Princess Makaveli.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Makaveli is Tupac's nickname,
and if you don't know that,
there's nothing I can do
to help you.
Also, he's still alive.
Then, in other toy news,
Mattel came out with
a Rosa Parks Barbie!
And I was like, "What?"
A real-life -- A real-life
activist gets their own Barbie?
Sweet!
Then the website was like,
"She led an ordinary life
as a seamstress
until one extraordinary moment."
And I was like, "Wait."
That's wrong.
She was a member of the NAACP
and she enacted
a well-thought-out plan.
Black people didn't accidentally
end up with rights.
People worked hard to get them.
That's like releasing
a Martin Luther King doll
and saying,
"He was an ordinary guy
until he accidentally
ended up at a podium."
"I have a dream?"
Then 17-year-old Swedish
activist Greta Thunberg
took a boat across
the Atlantic Ocean
to draw attention to climate
change, and I was like, "What?"
17?
What are the rules?
So you're telling me
a 17-year-old
can travel across the ocean
and a 15-year-old
can be in the U.S. Open?
Next you're going to tell me
a 22-year-old
can have her own segment
on a late-night talk show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then a White House aide
said Pence couldn't be anti-gay
because he's going to
have lunch this week
with the openly gay
prime minister of Ireland
and his partner.
And I was like, "What?"
Okay, just because
you spend an hour
in the same room with someone
does not mean you respect them.
My therapist hates my guts.
And also, I got major beef
with this show's
camera assistant Kenny,
and we work together every day.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]